Hello everybody, welcome to digging for XSS Gold, unearthing browser quirks with Shazza.
Shazza is a fuzzing tool built on a simple but powerful principle.
Don't look for bugs, look for differences.
Use the differences to find bugs.
Shazza helps you reveal security vulnerabilities by analysing deviations and unexpected behaviours.
So what exactly is fuzzing?
Well, fuzzing automates the process of asking millions of questions and receiving millions of answers.
Fuzzing typically involves generating a large number of inputs, either randomly or systematically,
and applying them to a target program, template, or system to detect unexpected behaviours or vulnerabilities.
Shazza is a tool designed to streamline the fuzzing process for web browsers by automating several tedious tasks.
Fuzzing typically involves generating loops, replacing data in templates, and storing results for different browsers.
Shazza simplifies this by handling browser detection, data storage, template generation, and placeholder insertion.
The name Shazza is derived from combining shared and fuzzer, reflecting on its goal to make fuzzing easier and shareable.
So now we know what Shazza is, let's focus on the fuzzing types.
What are the fuzzing types in Shazza?
Shazza has three fuzzing types, HTML, JS, and XSS.
The HTML type is used to understand how HTML is parsed.
For instance, if you need to determine what character can close a HTML comment, you would use the HTML fuz type.
It's more suitable when JavaScript execution is not required.
The JS type is used when JavaScript execution needs to be analysed.
The XSS type is needed when you need a combination of HTML and JavaScript.
One good example of this is when you need to know what characters are allowed before a HTML attribute.
The first example is a HTML fuzze template with placeholders for a character and the found tag.
Since the HTML fuzze type doesn't support JavaScript, the found tag is used to log the tag results.
If the fuzze character is greater than, for example, it will close the HTML comment, which exposes the found tag.
This specter helps you identify characters which close a HTML comment.
The second JavaScript example, we want to know what characters are allowed before an identifier.
The first placeholder is the character to fuzz.
And the second one is the iteration number of the fuzz or the character code.
The last example shows how you can check what characters are allowed before an on error event.
And those are the three fuzzing types in Shazza.
When I approach fuzzing, there's usually two approaches that I take.
It's useful to have a question in mind.
So, for example, what characters are allowed before the greater than that will still close the HTML comment?
Once you have that question in mind, you can tailor the template to answer that question.
Another way is to fuzz for existing behavior.
Let's imagine that the browser silently adds support for a new attribute quote using backticks.
You can find this behavior by fuzzing for the existing quote behavior.
So, the browser might accidentally add support for this character or it might be unspecked.
In this example, we place the placeholder before the greater than character.
And if this comment is successfully closed, the found tag will be found and it will log the results.
You might be thinking, well, this isn't going to happen.
But actually, it did happen on Firefox.
And I found multiple bugs where you could use new lines and it will still close the HTML comment using this trick.
In this example, I create a title attribute with two character placeholders.
Only if the characters act as an attribute quote will the on error event fire.
When running this vector, the single quotes and double quotes will be logged, confirming this quote behavior.
But hypothetically, if a browser introduced a new character that behaved in the same way,
you would see results for that browser.
So, if a browser accidentally added a certain character, you would see the results for those characters.
So, this is a new approach of fuzzing.
You fuzz for existing behavior as well as answering questions.
So, now we've covered the basics of Shazza, let's look at finding interesting browser behavior.
So, just a quick recap on URL credentials.
A URL can include credentials where the username and password are separated by a column and followed by an art symbol.
In Chrome, this is completely hidden from the user.
So, the credentials are there, but you can't see them.
And you can access these credentials client-side by using document.url, document.baseURI, or the URL constructor.
So, I recently researched hiding payloads in the credentials part of a URL by testing characters that don't URL encode.
So, to create a template, I first created an anchor tag, assigned a URL, and then fuzzed the username with different characters.
Then, I checked if the browser encoded them, revealing which characters are allowed.
So, in this example, I use code before the fuzz.
So, this creates the element.
And then, the template is used to do the actual fuzzing.
Whilst researching DOM XSS, I aim to identify what characters' browsers don't URL encode in the URL.
So, I used the DOM again, and I used a JavaScript fuzz type.
But this time, I assigned to the anchor hash, and then checked that property to see if it had been URL encoded by the browser.
So, this would put up interesting results if the browser wasn't URL encoded.
So, so far, we've covered fuzzing single characters.
But Shazza can do more than that.
A template can also fuzz data, like HTML tags, attributes, entities.
You basically define your own data that you want to fuzz.
Choose it from the select menu.
So, you choose the data1 or data2 placeholder to fuzz.
And then, when you create that vector, you can use those placeholders to fuzz that data.
So, you could be fuzzing attributes.
You could be fuzzing HTML tags.
You could be looking for crashes.
You could be looking for interesting behavior.
But you can use the data in Shazza to enumerate on that data.
In this vector, I create a div element and assign an anchor tag.
I then use the placeholder data1 to insert various entities for fuzzing.
So, after each iteration, I check the host property of the anchor.
And if it differs from example.com, it will allow me to detect if the injected entity has altered the intended URL.
So, I use the data1 placeholder to insert the entity.
So, in the example, I use code before the fuzz to create the div.
Then, I assign the anchor to the div.
And then, I use the data1 placeholder to insert the entity.
And then, after the code, after each fuzz, I check the host property and then log the results.
In this vector, I enumerate all entities, checking which ones convert to the greater man character.
An iframe is created with an entity assigned via the data1 placeholder to the src doc.
After each fuzz iteration, the src doc attribute is checked using the include function to determine if the character was decoded.
This was cool because it would find you any entities that convert to a greater man.
After you've fuzzed your vectors, you can view the vector on the vector overview page.
So, let's check out the last vector results.
Shazer will generate some sample payloads based on the data that it's found.
So, in our fuzzing process, we targeted entities that convert to greater than.
In this sample, you can see that both ampersandGT and ampersandNVGT meet this condition.
So, this is just a sample of data, which Shazer will show you what entities or what data is being converted.
Shazer will show you what entities are being converted to the data.
So, after the sample payloads, then we have the actual fuzz results for the browser.
What Shazer does is only expand the browser results if they differ.
So, it'll contract all the other browsers unless they have a different behavior than another one.
In this example, it shows the data in the form of entities.
And you can sort the data by filtering out alphanumerics and show only the differences.
So, I don't know if you can see, but in this example, I show ampersandGT, ampersandGT in uppercase, and ampersandNVGT.
All these create the greater than character, which can be used for XSS on some obscure system.
When fuzzing characters, Shazer will generate a table with the decimal number of each character, the hex representation of it, and the character itself.
In this sample, it's highlighted 39, which is the character code for a single quote.
And this is because at least one browser had different behavior.
So, it will highlight in red when one browser differs out of all the browsers that have been tested.
And this is really useful for finding deviations and unexpected behavior.
So, when building Shazer, I faced a bit of a challenge, sharing vectors with others.
To make this possible, I needed to eliminate XSS risks on the Shazer domain.
Without this, a malicious vector could compromise somebody else's account.
This next section covers how I tackled this problem.
So, when designing Shazer, I followed a few core principles.
First of all, all the data is public, eliminating private vectors that could be targeted for theft.
Second, there's no private data stored.
By removing all private information like email addresses, the system holds no sensitive information to steal.
Lastly, I chose GitHub as the SSO provider, ensuring there are no passwords to steal on the system at any point.
So, by designing the system without any data that you can steal, even in a compromise, there'll be a lot less damage than a normal website.
All vectors are executed within an iframe sandbox configured with allow scripts and allow form flags.
To enable scripts and forms will prevent an attacker from breaking out of the frame.
The SRC dock attribute is used to assign the template and the fuzzing architecture,
ensuring that everything runs securely within the sandbox environment.
I also use CSP to prevent excessive server requests, such as laws that may occur with image resources.
Once fuzzing is complete, a web message is sent to the parent page.
The parent then validates this message by comparing the message source property with the iframe's content window.
After a valid message has been received, the SRC of the iframe is cleared, and then that will remove any residual content.
So, the source property is really important here because if you use the origin, the origin will be null.
So, by using the source property, you can verify the iframe's window is the expected window that you're expecting.
So, here's how it works.
The user presses the fuzz button.
The template and architecture is assigned to the SRC dock attribute.
The sandbox iframe is then rendered, showed here in red.
It blocks access to cookies and the alerts and prompts and stuff.
And then the fuzz results are then sent to the parent page.
So, this is the main Shazam window.
It receives that message.
The parent page receives a message, validates it, comes from the sandbox iframe, and then the fuzz results are stored.
So, all you do is you look at the web message, use the event source property, and compare it with the iframe content window.
And this verifies that the message is genuine.
Now, you might get a problem, what I encountered, where you've got an extension installed, and it'll send a message to the event listener.
So, if you do this, then you won't get that problem.
So, like, for example, Reacts dev tools, they will send messages to listeners on the page.
And then by comparing the source property, you can remove that.
So, this is the main reason why I validate the messages.
And obviously, it also validates malicious messages too.
So, in this section, I'll explore some more advanced vectors and demonstrate how you can leverage advanced placeholders.
So, this vector detects which tags consume HTML, and it could be used to bypass a HTML filter.
I think Masato Kinogawa used this technique to get XSS on Google, for example.
So, in this example, the found tag will only be detected if the fuzz tag consumes the HTML and the image is not rendered.
So, I've given an example of the text area because everybody can understand that.
It's quite simple.
You use a text area, and unless you get a closing text area, it will just treat the resulting text as text, not as HTML.
So, you can use this with a text area, but it also works with other tags, such as no embed, no script, etc.
So, you can use Shazer to detect this sort of behavior.
And that's really important because finding this sort of behavior can lead to a filter bypass, XSS, etc.
So, here, the two examples show the text area and the no embed tag.
But I've fuzzed other tags, and there are many other tags that have this behavior.
Another thing to look for when fuzzing is that some tags will prevent other tags from rendering.
And you can find this behavior by using the not found placeholder.
This will only log data if the not found tag isn't found, as the name suggests.
So, in this example, the script will not execute because the style neutralizes it.
This is really good for finding HTML parsing quirks.
For example, you get different behavior if you use an SVG tag with style, and if you use XML with style, or if you use HTML with style.
So, this is really interesting to find because it can lead to bypasses and unexpected parsing quirks.
So, in HTML attributes, entities get decoded.
Meaning, if you use the log function, the entity will be decoded before being passed to it.
So, this is a problem.
So, to solve this, you need to use an advanced placeholder that escapes the entity before logging it.
I'll demonstrate how you do this on the next slide.
To identify which entities can be used as a JavaScript variable,
first, you can assign the entity with the placeholder data1 to the shazer log function like here.
When calling the function, the HTML data1 placeholder to encode the entity before passing it to the function.
So, you use the entity in three places.
One, to define the variable name.
One, when calling the actual variable as a function, and then storing the data.
One, to define the entity in three places.
!
If the entity in three places.
If the entity.
Is it possible.
To fuzz.
More than two.
Data sets.
At a time.
The answer is.
No.
Not the minute.
You can.
You have a maximum.
Data sets.
Of.
Two separate.
Data sets.
You can't.
Go all about.
At the minute.
And the reason.
For that is.
It's going to take.
A long time.
Because.
The amount.
Of data.
You've got.
Per data set.
It's like.
Times that.
By the other data set.
And then times it again.
For another data set.
And that's only three levels.
So it's on log data.
So that's the reason.
Why I don't really do that.
At the minute.
Um.
Uh.
Someone's asked.
So this is in.
So this is.
In.
Do you.
Do you still have.
Up the database.
Of all.
The old.
Yes I do.
And I can get.
Your specific.
Vectors.
If you want.
Them.
But obviously.
I can't.
Sure.
Anybody else's.
Fuzzing.
To your email research.
Yes I have.
I did.
An SNTP.
Fuzzer.
Um.
That was really useful.
In finding.
Behaviour.
In.
Postfix.
And send mail.
Um.
Like.
The backslash.
Stuff.
Um.
Yeah.
The presentation.
Will be recorded.
Um.
Sorry.
If you missed it.
Um.
Somebody.
Asked.
There's a specific.
Case of.
HTML injection.
Where.
You've got.
The.
HTTPS protocol.
Before.
The JavaScript.
URL.
Uh.
Don't think.
XSS.
Will be possible.
Unless you can.
Break out.
The attribute.
Unfortunately.
Um.
And.
Is there.
Any.
Methodology.
We can.
Follow.
To do.
This.
Kind.
Of.
Fuzzing.
Yeah.
I believe.
I touched.
On.
That.
In.
The.